[Music]
hi everyone welcome back to the lobby
GameSpot's weekly video game hangout
here at 11 a.m. Pacific in San Francisco
California I'm your host Mike McCarty
here with Pete brown reviews editor Oh
me yeah you guys coffee finally people
were threatened about him not having
that so the day is saved
Rob Henry hi who just turned whose
birthday was yesterday
happy birthday I am I don't have to I
just meant like yesterday was your
birthday belated happy belated thank you
very much 30 what are you doing give me
birthday plans this weekend yeah the
every year Fleet Week lines up pretty
nicely with my birthday for those who
don't know a fleet week is the Navy and
I think military overall US military
kind of shows off their you know flexes
a little bit airshow namely the airshow
Blue Angels yeah I'll shake the city and
it's it's like I love playing rob was
kind enough to wake up at 6:30 the day
after his birthday to play battlefront
two's beta for pre-order customers so we
will be talking about that that'll be
open on Friday we'll talk more about
that but thanks for waking up so early
so we had more to talk about cuz I did
not wake up that early yeah thanks for
not getting totally twisted I did not I
did not get hammered last night thanks
for your hard work
Kelly Blackie what's up hi it's me
you've been playing a hat in time is
that it yes I just hatton time I think
it's a hat in time 3d platformer we'll
talk more about that or talk about that
but we're also going to get into cuphead
because we didn't get the chance to talk
too much about it last week we got the
chance to play more of it Pete you
reviewed it cuphead Joey got really good
all that we have a giveaway as always
but I do have a few news items I want to
get through Forza Motorsport 7 is out
now is our full review up or still there
last night's miguel concepción wrote it
what does he think of it 8 points out of
10 points 8 out of 10 agreed out of 10
on Xbox one very good looking game yeah
and with the weather physics kick in
yeah pretty much it's like forces back
still really good and they've done a lot
of really cool stuff with the weather
now so it's a more impressive looking
game than ever and you can also get more
out of a single track you know see in a
different light and that was one of the
few things that you liked about the game
quite a bit there were some modes that
were missing that rat launched from
other forces which you know like a
little disappointing I suppose if people
like those modes and it's not like
McGill did so he missed them a little
bit there rolling them out later or I
think unconfirmed I don't know but yeah
a great racing game cool I want to play
more that I played a lot of Forza
horizon 3 yeah because I mean obviously
very different that's more arcadey kind
of open-world you like turn on yeah
open-world yeah the rkt yes but you can
turn on a lot of assists in four to
seven it sounds like that might actually
ease you into something like this recent
games are super therapeutic yeah me
unless I'm losing which is all the time
so I don't like battlefront 2 story
trailer also went up last week we got to
watch that show died in verse CEO and
her dad who was like a admiral talking
to one of the Holograms left behind by
Palpatine the sentinels they had their
guys in the red cloaks who are creepily
able to glide across the floor I really
liked this mm-hmm scene it was short and
sweet but it did a really great job of
like setting the tone and the the kind
of the overarching plot we talked about
it once before in the lobby as far as
you know they they mentioned operation
cinder which is which is what the
Emperor had in play if he were to die
well he died and so it goes into play
and he basically has like I think it's
like half a dozen of these dudes relay
his his last final wishes which is yeah
this operation cinder which you know
finally stamp out the rebels so to speak
no no actually not necessarily it was
his operation Saturday's cinder is
basically that's that cider I know
cinder is basically to destroy the
Empire and have a select few of the
Imperial elites to then fleeing to the
outer rim of the galaxy basically
basically like a full-on retreat but
like destroy what is
remaining of the Empire and then to flee
and start again okay and basically what
we now know is the first order oh so it
really is a you know a middle story
between or linking you know the original
trilogy with the new trilogy cool I
think that is awesome
so cool I mean I know that like they
have to work with Lucas to to get these
stories approved anyway so it's it's
just really cool to see such a
high-profile theme factored into those
movies we're excited until a story they
like you know you know you can argue
that like the the standalone upcoming
movies of Han Solo and Bubba Fett and
you know now obi-wan it's like Boba Fett
Boba Fett whatever its who who really
wants that I mean I don't I want some
new grounds you know at least there's
kind of like rests in between like I
don't want like I'm trying to jaunty
Star Wars game or movie yeah you know it
again and the same goes for a game right
like yeah so I think that's really neat
and again like the this plot of like
operation cinder was or at least part of
it was already implemented in there are
newer comics so but it's but it's all
the new and official Canon that Disney
has created it so like they're pulling
from that it sounds like in a really
cool way and also telling a new story of
this iDEN inverse she's a yeah Janina
gavankar if i'm pronouncing that
correctly she was shiva in the league
she was somewhat community kind of crime
yes she looks like she's doing a very
good job based on the story trailer so
far she did the presentation at EAS
conference III right oh she had the
coolest dress super Star Wars he right
there was shared a cool dress in
something that was really excited about
it yeah but like just again that's seen
like the the acting and the the tone
like you're just hearing like that that
underlining like Imperial like drone
like whoa
all that it's like that that was very
much Stowers so way that like sentinel
like reacted when she was like so what's
the other thing he was you are not
permitted or he has there's plans that
the foot soldiers don't know about
assuming you'll find out later and there
will be some sort of moral quandary they
and they and they had showed i think it
was like behind-the-scenes video on the
single-player that they put out and i
was like you've got a brief glimpse of
like the different characters in her
inferno squad and you can already see
like pretty neat ideas hopefully you
know they're executed well and this
thing comes out but it's like you know
you know maybe like a full-on obsessed
imperial soldier or like maybe one who's
skeptical you know characters basically
that can like pull and tug on her own
opinion of VMR and where it stands like
you know we don't know if she's gonna
defect or you know can i do a thin kind
of also walt williams who helped right
SpecOps the line one of the main writers
on he was helping write this too so that
game was very good at kind of bringing
up questions that played toyed with your
expectations of a first-person shooter
mmm so looking forward to that that'll
be out November 17th we're gonna talk
more about the multiplayer cuz P if you
like I said if you pre-ordered it you
get the chance to play on ps4 Xbox one
or PC today and then open beta for
everybody on Friday I believe it's just
the Naboo map right and galactic assault
so that yeah we can talk about that more
okay cool it's a quickly I guess because
there might not be too much talk about
did you play a call duty to world war
two the bottle Duty World War two beta
yeah pc beta played a brief amount of PC
beta but yeah I mean it was the same
thing as the cost ones like death a sure
you play one of those other modes
there's only four or five modes like
hardpoint team da our domination your
standard call duty staples your standard
so yeah yeah it's three maps and then
the war mode which is where I have the
most fun or so far I've been enjoying
the most that war mode so after the pc
beta you're still feeling that way cuz
like last time we talked about we all we
were all kind of
yeah everything else is like Call of
Duty and then war mode is interesting
it's different yeah fun and if it feels
like it really carries over the world
war 2 aesthetic nicely I think with like
the frontlines are established you know
you're doing like objective taste of
stuff even though the bridge building
looks extremely funny the idea of it
just going prone and just it reminds me
of I mean obviously there are liberty
liberties they're taking with
attachments and these aperture sights
and silencers on this submachine gun I
mean yeah things like that did exist but
they weren't as pervasive as they are in
this but they did that with world at war
right because they had to bring over
that modern warfare progression system
to the world war ii aesthetic so it
seems like there's more of that you know
like as we assume there would be yeah it
seems like they do a good job with that
kind of thing though about making it not
like obtrusive being like this would
never have happened yeah right like the
lens on the red dot it's not necessarily
a red dot right yeah like hologram but
it's like kind of an older looking scope
you know like like very much concave so
it's got like that
fisheye you know I mean like it's not
ideal or perfect
right they they push it
they push the boundaries nicely I think
cool yeah people asking bodman in the
twitch chat we are we do take audience
interaction of course not like somebody
was just saying are you open to talking
about my gripe to the Forza Motorsport 7
I probably won't get too in-depth of
that but if you have any questions
obviously in the YouTube and twitch
chats as always I'm in there I'm
monitoring that I'll hit you up if you
have a good question or comment so that
is called 2d World War 2 PC beta that
game is not too far away either that's
like the week after mario odyssey
assassin's creed origin and oh he's the
reviews under here is freaking out about
all these games come on man yeah yeah
cuz it's it's that October 27th day I
would say like crazy day but it's it's
gonna be fun but it for free for people
like you that worried about reviews and
everything and it'll be busy the week
after that is called Duty World War two
and then a week two weeks after that is
Battlefront 2 so yeah we're getting into
the business
this is kind of last week when it's not
crazy I would say the shadow force
Tuesday evil then - it is Friday you can
start crying
you know it's tomorrow stardew valley on
Smith and axiom verge starting Valley on
switch that and axiom verge on Swisher
what is started Valley I'm gonna finally
dive into I've only ever played like
four hours I was I called in sick one
day not to play star to Valley I called
in sick one day and there's like Oh
started valleys out so I was like in bed
with a fever and for four hours played
and I don't remember it anymore carrots
yes I put a hundred sixty hours into the
PC version that's too many and that is
probably the least ideal platform for
the kind of game that I want to play in
bed so I'm really really worried about
how many hours I'm gonna put inside but
it's also like this is a great game I
feel like to do kind of like 20-minute
bite-sized segments right when you're on
the way to work it isn't it isn't I mean
it depends on what you're doing like I
liked going into the mines on rainy days
and like trying to get you know there's
that kind of grind erpg um almost
dungeon crawler aspect to this game I
know I like the variety in starry Valley
I'm just so excited I could not be more
excited unload it as soon as I possibly
can so okay I played for hours and I
don't even think I got into the main
like loop at that point what is now so I
don't not really a big Animal Crossing
fan I like Minecraft and I know there's
some aspects of that kind of game in
here but I've never played like Harvest
Moon either it's like for someone who
may not have played this when I was on
PC or any other platforms and they have
a switch now and they're trying to play
every game possible that comes to switch
because it's a great pet platform to
play on with axiom verge and yesterday
lovers in a dangerous space-time bunch
of games last week which we could talk a
little more about what about stardew
valley should excite me like can in a
nutshell like for people who don't know
sell me on it um well it definitely
evokes that old Harvest Moon feeling not
like the newer Harvest Moon games back
when it was
Harshman proper and not story of seasons
but I think one of the the strongest
things about it is it blends in the RPG
elements really nicely so like I said
there's
you know you can go down into the mines
and they have different levels and you
unlock new things you can open up new
areas and that progression I think is
more satisfying than some more recent
farming games for example I think for
people who find kind of like the daily
chore simulator games a little slow I
think that feedback loop helps in speed
up the game if that makes sense
if you're if you're the kind of person
who thinks that you know farming games
or animal crossing or something like
that is a little too slow I think that
sense of progression really helps it and
that's one of my favorite things about
it ok well it's also so peaceful and I
like you you know you can unlock things
to put in this community center and
there's yearly events and it's just
there's there's so much to love about it
I am the holiday events - or was that
just part of the story there it's not
like it's not real time the way Animal
Crossing is it's you know you you just
progress through a day you can if you
have done everything you can just go to
bed and the next day will happen ok but
depending on how long I think I would
spend maybe 20 to 40 minutes in a day
and so once you get to like the the
harvest season there's like a harvest
event and you can get married and you
can you know dance at the spring dance
or whatever there's different like
hometown farming town events okay yeah
because I I'm surprised to seeing the
gameplay that you go into mines and
stuff I even know that was part of I
thought yeah farming yeah there's
actually a much wider variety of things
to do than just farming and you'd be
surprised I think one of the coolest
things is going into that community
center and like there's different rooms
and it'll be like oh you need these for
fruits from spring season and if you
missed that you have to wait until the
next year
so part of like people who try to like
complete the community center as quickly
as possible have like speedrun plans for
how to get like I need all of these
items and I can only do it in spring and
so I'm gonna fish these fish and give it
to the community center okay so there's
that cool aspect too so needless to say
you're excited for that tomorrow on
switch yeah axiom verge the more kind of
retro classic Metroidvania a game that
came out I think at this point
three years ago no it's 2015 sorry two
years ago that's coming to switch as
well tomorrow and this also seems great
for the switch have you really can you
talk about it it's exactly what you
think cool I mean it's not graphically
demanding right although it is pretty
gorgeous this ant star valley on the
back of the nest classic seems like good
timing in terms of these kind of games
yeah your retro inspired yeah I mean
axiom verge is super kind of classic I
get lost in that game a lot and I played
it three times at this point yeah it's I
think where I liked the efficiency ins
in famous returns I'm looking back at
axiom Birds I'm like maybe it was
reaching too hard to be a vague or I
don't know but but but that is still
like a good quality like the game still
has that sense of exploration and
immersion and like this this big world
which well it's kind of missing from
Sandra's returns in a way because you
were directed so much but yeah it's a
great game it'll last you a long time
there's some like really weird like
glitch worlds that exist that are like
you find him in the environment and you
go into this world that is like way too
difficult but like that's where you find
some pretty rad [ __ ] so Clark Anderson
used to be a GameSpot former editor
turned engineer oh right he was
speedrunning that game in like two hours
or something yeah we shortly after a see
yeah I was like a week after it launched
we did a couple streams where he was
speedrunning it and I think like for
like a day or something like he was like
one of the fastest but it took like two
days for somebody but yeah any minutes
you know i've hand if we have that like
archived on YouTube or anything
oh we must yeah he's at twitch now but
yeah he super like that game a lot and
that was made by how many people made
that game through Thomas Happ basically
deserves all the credit okay we'd spent
five five years don't stop working in
this game Wow yeah cool so that is that
on switch as of tomorrow Thursday you
check that out alongside stardew valley
if you're into that as long as what you
were talking about sign amaura Cinna
Maura
Sinha Maura bullet hellish kind of game
that came out with three years ago at
this point yeah I think
one of the smartest you know bullet-hell
shooters out there essentially the pitch
is every level you have a time where
that counts down it's not enough time to
finish the level the only way to get
more time is by killing enemies but
sometimes the challenges in front of you
are so difficult that you actually want
to use the ability to slow down time but
doing that costs time from your timer so
you're constantly saying am i do is the
opportunity cost thing yeah right so you
know my confident can I do this on my
own [ __ ] no I couldn't so I gotta I
gotta go back and try it again and do
that super dark story wonderful graphics
grasshopper manufacturer didn't develop
the game single-handedly but they worked
with digital reality to make it that
studio also made Black Knight sword
which is sort of a forgotten game that
was a very difficult very dark
platformer
that's just anymore right here
beautiful-looking reviewed really well
years ago didn't sell that well it's
very interesting GDC Europe talk online
about it but I or this game and as
someone who thinks that our kid shooters
are a lot of fun to pick up and play but
maybe they lack substance this accounts
for that deficit so think of someone
like next machina or resogun this would
be something to check out are they
similar enough yeah they are I mean I
think there's more substance to this
game than those games cool so yeah I
mean that definitely definitely play
this if you know especially coming off
of cup head to like if you like that
sort of twist like side-scrolling
shooter stuff I got I got nothing but
praise for this game yeah this is also
on switch now along with I mean I played
golf story all weekend actually I want
to get into that soon first yeah before
we get into more of those switch games
Rob you were showing us the demo of this
survival not even survival horror just
like this horror first-person shooter
called scorns every gross looking game
as cord yeah what's this um what's the
style I keep
gigoo both craft I guess like HR Giger
okay yeah yeah wouldn't say it's
Lovecraft necessarily yeah yeah I mean
there's your body I do love it it's like
your skin has been in a it's a real
goopy game yeah like you wanna yeah
reminds me of like the interior of like
the the Covenant ship from a galleon you
know yeah
but with another layer of like blood and
[ __ ] to him almost it really gave me
doomed vibes yeah so yeah they did this
they did this alpha demo that I would
say is roughly about 15 minutes however
I would say this is just more of an
example or like a a tech demo slash like
just tonight just like an idea because
the first part are the first time you
load it up it says like this this game
is not done the content and what you do
and the puzzles have all been changed so
yeah that's your ammo you're putting to
be referred to as a slice yeah
that being said like you basically just
over you know it's super mysterious you
literally have like no texts you just
are observing your environment like
unlocking doors its puzzle heavy but
also this is version this techid then I
was like permadeath so when you died you
started from the beginning really so
it's a trial and error your cuz you go
into these rooms and it's like a bunch
of white smoke spews out and you're dead
it's like okay I don't go in that room
that's again so it actually took me a
while so 1337 studio is this person was
pointing out in the YouTube chat this is
episode one of two according to a
Kickstarter page so interesting software
has been working on it for two years but
recently I believe late August they took
it to Kickstarter to get that final foot
push for funding so at this is called
scorn part 1 of 2 according to
Kickstarter and whatnot it was very
clarification the offer that we're
playing is not part 1 of 2 like this
literally just no vertical so maybe part
1 & 2 just to give an idea of like look
this is the setting these are the things
you can do in a very quick sort of like
you know summary and it really does give
you a good sense of the aesthetic yeah
which is I mean that's the thing that
hit me the strongest I mean absolutely
that you hear like the viscera
squelching yeah that's a good I will say
so I haven't got gotten a chance to play
the alpha but I was watching you know
videos of it and one of the things that
interested me was the the weapon
specifically I mean you saw early early
you kind of ripped the
like you have these a universal handy
yeah thing apart but the thing on an
ascii is the loading seemed to painfully
slow and they seem to be like
intentionally yeah there's like that's
one of the things works like I don't
know if that works well we're yeah it's
it's supposed to be intentionally slow
there so there's that panic induced
feeling you get when you're when you're
getting swarmed by these aliens there's
no way that slow it loading this weapon
like it's so slow you totally know it's
like dropping bullets everywhere I'm
shaking like he's very deliberately it
doesn't fit feeding the bullets into it
and it's that that there's this thing so
think this this thing comes out and just
immediately dying so you need to puzzle
think so you you know you're moving that
white alien from one room to the other
so you can get through you know I mean
like there's a lot of puzzle stuff and
then the end you approach a door and it
just sends but I would say yeah there's
that there's some things that I think
are questionable the other one is the
permit of death where it's like I really
hope they don't like that sounds more up
liable to this demo this permadeath idea
or it's like I died and I can't say even
I start from the beginning again because
walking down these corridors again for
the you know six time gets pretty
tedious so I would have to imagine it's
like just meant to like keep you playing
and indulging into the ambience of this
game but yeah I don't know I don't know
what the final product is really it's
still super mysterious yeah I think
they're weird
yeah I mean it's it I do get do vibes it
does seem Silent Hill yeah there's a lot
of things that seem kind of old about it
if that makes sense
like it clearly looks really good
there's there's like this cool aesthetic
they're going for and there's this cool
weapon but the actual way it looks to
walk through these corridors and stuff
just seems old I don't know how else to
put it right I'm done tight like sure
people have done it already
oh no you're exactly right that's like
it when I was finished with this then I
was like alright well I guess I'm done
like I don't know like I I need yeah
there's definitely some like features
that are active
well the other thing about too is your
ammo is that you also realize in this
demo that you you have a limited amount
so I ran out of bullets
so you like then play again and you're
so great I guess I'll die I'll just die
then do you have to like conserve so
yeah I don't we'll have to see but this
thing becomes yeah so ways to go so this
that gameplay clip is presumably up on
gamespot and our YouTube channel
yep sorry I was remembering this yeah
you go check us out if you're watching
this live if you're watching this after
the fact again that's up on gamespot
youtube now kind of to double back to
the switch i want to talk more about
like I think was last week 14 games got
added to the switch something around to
that number to that effect but you know
kind of including but not limited to
golf story which I want to talk more
about I really like that game I played a
lot over the weekend Peter I know you
dabbled with it and I don't know if you
guys got the chance to play lots of
questions about cost okay cool and also
the negative space shooter in versus
deluxe I don't know what negative space
means but that's what our news writer
wrote and I don't too much about that
game demo the fantasy rhythm game and
then also Nintendo's arcade archives
Mario Bros was a few days before that
and then of course sin amaura X or X how
we want to say it again there are many
more yesterday was lovers in dangerous
space-time a really fun co-op arcade
shooter that was inspired by the scene
in a new hope Orhan and Luke climb into
the turret to the Millennium Falcon
where you're kind of piloting the ship
around you play that have you played it
Rob it's very fun it's it's simple but
it's you actually you're guiding the
circular spaceship through space but you
have two people so you can jump to pilot
the ship or you can jump into the
turrets it's very fun
you get shields and whatnot to check
that out I'm curious how co-op works on
switch probably pretty streamlined I
would imagine yeah oh joy cons that game
would probably work well with joy cons
[Music]
yeah like don't get cocky that was the
worst Han Solo ever done but yeah golf
story I've been playing that kind of
old-school RPG inspired golf game in a
nutshell maybe so do you had questions I
have questions yeah because this game
looks so beautiful like I love the it's
I don't know you
call it charming yeah like a charming
art style but really interests me but I
am worried that I will get bored with
the Gulf can I enjoy this game if I'm
not a big fan of like golfing I'm yeah I
like golf so I can't say I'm not the
biggest fan of golf but maybe I like
video game golf more than golfing
concept sure and the nice thing about
this game is you can at any point it's
not like you go from hole to hole all
the time or you go to course you can
literally just be like to throw a ball
down here and you can be talking to
someone be like yeah totally drop the
ball and just tee off while he's talking
there's like random holes and flags all
over the place and you can kind of just
like it sounds cool it's more just like
a like a pastime kind of thing you don't
Nick Marguerite has been playing a lot
of it but I guess for me I'm not I don't
play too many golf games I like to
everybody's golf for how are Katie they
made that I think they did a good job
with this of kind of making the golf
it's very it's very classic yeah yeah
yeah and I still I'm having fun with it
just because I think they they made a
one I was doing this part the first area
you walking around and you kind of get
these side quests from everybody whether
you're trying to they're like betting
you money so you can make money to get
coaching lessons from this guy that
doesn't really believe in oh I love the
the writing of it in terms of I don't
know if you're watching this right now
you can kind of see every once in a
while but they'll italicize things and
you can kind of get a sense of the tone
of the people that are talking to you
which people are super sarcastic it's
actually pretty funny hmm
oh wait this guy's especially your coach
off the rumble for the love of yeah this
game the HD 5 there are some news on
switch that I just cannot stand because
they're HD Rumble is not new on every
single text window you see yeah has a
hey developers fix your [ __ ] it's stupid
no one likes it well it's not as bad as
he saying oh my god it's been rice which
is broken because it's probably I will
say the first party games use the HD
Rumble a lot better I think yeah yeah
for me what I have played yeah I'm sorry
Mike it's really bad every text window
it vibrates every sex window but it
doesn't like shake no firing room like
you've got out you've got to hold my
switch my switch must be broken because
there's
something really here was showing me he
was washing rocks with it but it is
super annoying I would say that so maybe
turn it off I guess that's your best bet
right now and tell your home but it is
very much people are comparing it to is
it earthbound in terms of the tone of
the writing that just because that's
shorthand for irreverence yeah when
you're talking about like again on the
back of the cess classic between this
axiom verge stardew valley it seems like
this kind of retro feel it seems in this
few weeks it's it's cool because you
have those like you know not original
Nintendo games but you know classic
Nintendo games coming out and then these
are games that are clearly inspired by
that classic style but they're you know
they're indie and you sing that indie
support on a Nintendo system is just
really cool and I'm very excited about
how many smaller interesting charming
cool games that were getting on switch
it's really promising to me our boys
coming to switch eventually platformer
right I just like right to de it's not
quite a Metroidvania it's definitely on
a platformer necessarily but it's a
side-scrolling action game that's got a
lot of heart the amazing soundtrack
great artwork so beautiful like broody
like you don't want a heart and good
soundtrack thank John Astin Alden you
just take the flag in the hall I didn't
know you'd do that I'll say yeah you see
that you can you see the T areas right
here where you can actually like T a
traditional golf I guess but otherwise
people will the first area is very
tutorial izing like how to get out of
bunkers what clubs to use and everything
but it's they streamlined the actual
golf aspects it can still be fairly
in-depth with approach shots and
different irons and whatnot but I'm
having fun with it I only just realized
those weird violins on the left are
actually golf bags oh my god I initially
thought they were cellos yeah check this
out its size it's worth it
I like liking a lot
was kind of in a slew of other games but
this is one of the ones that stood out
that came to switch recently I wish one
criticism I'll have I wish the switch
was better at collating these and kind
of like golf story was kind of up there
I had to dig a little bit but when you
go to the eShop it's just it's tough to
find all of the new things I wish
there's not a new releases section there
is but it's it's flooded by so many
other things that are just kind of
inconsequential I would say as opposed
to like golf story in cinah more I had
Santa Maura I didn't see right away at
all I just wish there was easier to find
like I mean like you got a PlayStation
Network and they're promoted stuff is
usually pretty in your face bye now bye
bye sounds like your thing Kelly you've
also been playing a hat in time mm-hmm
which is a 3d platformer yes how's it
going are you reviewing it I'm reviewing
it soon I I think I'm about 75% done
with it um I really like it it's the I
was talking to Ben Janko yesterday about
how this is kind of the game that I the
kind of feeling I wanted to have playing
ukulele not that it's extremely similar
to a banjo or a ukulele but I mean like
at first I was not super into it the
first world I think is it's kind of
generic but it's definitely good
tutorial and then I got into it and I
was like okay I need to go back I need
to find everything because there's these
kind of hidden levels they're like
challenge levels with just pure
platforming and they are really really
fun I was really impressed by the the
depth there's I mean like you can play
this game just play it straight through
and just get like the the cutesy like
I'm just having a good time a good play
through it pretty easily I think
although there's like a level where
there's just dudes hanging from nooses I
don't know if I would give it to a young
child but in this yeah this bird is yeah
the Richard Simmons friend I'm sorry I
can't move past this there are people
hanging from nooses in this game yes
they're not really people creatures
they're ancient things they're like
little corpses little ghost boys
hanging from yeah but but I really liked
that level it was the spooky level of
course um but like I was saying I think
they did a good job of scaling it to
here's like the easy surface level stuff
you can do and then there was there were
some actually really challenging 3d
platforming things I mean not really
challenging I mean we'll talk about
cuphead which is very challenging later
but um I just liked that there were
there was a you could kind of scale it
to how challenging you wanted it to be
so I'm excited to play more today this
how long was this in Kickstarter how
long ago because I'm seeing some of its
backer rewards get delivered February
2014 yeah it's been in development for a
long time like six years I think Spanish
studio I was a little surprised when I
mentioned this in the office never was
like a what in time and it was like what
really ukelele overshadow what you think
I don't know maybe I mean this was
pitched a long time ago it got some
coverage and it was sort of pitched as
like a hey this is like a Mario 64 kind
of like yeah because the original this
is an office at the top their
Kickstarter page says something to the
effect of like oh it's like super mario
64 banjo kazooie Psychonauts these games
aren't made anymore I was like well
Mario does he's right around the corner
but like I said this was a while ago and
they said that hey I will say I'm just
knowing that it's been in development
for a while it's kind of funny that the
whole conceit is the hats which I didn't
touch on at all but basically you have
different hats with different powers and
so it is kind of funny that it's all
about the Hat which is another thing
that Ben Jacob pointed out yesterday but
I do think the Hat thing is really cool
because you need to find yarn to knit
new hats to get special powers and that
is a that's another layer to -
encouraging you to explore and see
everything that a level has to offer
who are these jamokes following you
right now I haven't done this level I've
been in this area I've beaten this level
with this dude but this must be a bonus
level I haven't done yet you look like
stray cats or jazz cats yeah
jazz flutes initially so this is
actually really cool this one
of a warring bird movie studio level
like West Side Story yeah so there's the
there's this level which is like kind of
like the dance DJ you know like you're a
diva and then there's the like old
western train movie level which is like
in sepia and it's really really cool
I've seen footage of that yeah that
seems kind of dark
yeah like first the tone and like that I
know like people are getting murdered
you're investing like crimes you're
investigating a murder yeah this game
does have I think some weird tonal
shifts yeah but I liked I do think like
like I said the first level I wasn't
that impressed with it seemed kind of
generic and then after that the level
design got a lot more creative and the
the world themes and stuff like that so
it was very busy there's a lot going on
it's the other one is much more plain
because it's all in sepia but yeah so
your review will essentially be up
soonish yes Amy for tomorrow cuz this
game comes out tomorrow PC ps4 Xbox one
yes October 5th you're listening to this
after the fact then you can play it
right now I guess but if you're watching
live yeah it comes out tomorrow Kelly
your review will be up on GameSpot in
the coming days hopefully tomorrow but
yeah so you can get more in depth of
that if you want to check out more of a
hat in time from gears for breakfast
with the new studio Kickstarter project
cool curious for breakfast yeah
pieces of gears like battle chasers
night war this is explain this game to
me because you were saying you play this
at e3 and it was super fun yeah and you
said it was kind of unfortunate because
battle chaser sounds like a mobile game
I guess so yeah yeah I mean it is sort
of like alright look out for switch
stuff switch is hot and I heard
turn-based RPG on switch she's like okay
yeah holy [ __ ] it's got the art from Joe
Madeira the guy whose comic book artist
for a long time and contributed to
Darksiders I was like all right now I'm
really interested in I went and I met
him and I played the game and I really
liked it a whole lot it's so it's a
turn-based RPG you're essentially you've
crashed landed on this island and you're
trying to get off the island but you get
wrapped up into a conflict and in the
process of that conflict you end up
going through
there's like eight major dungeons and
there's some smaller ones they're all
procedurally generated as you can see
the art style is just my opinion awesome
yeah I like it a lot Diablo vibe I guess
it does yeah
the combat is where the game really
shines and I think it's either for you
it depends on what you'd like to do like
so our review is up it got a six out of
ten from Justin Clark you know he
everyone has their own taste and how
combat works I think maybe I like this
more than he did so one of the things in
the game is like stacking debuff sand
sort of managing how you can impact your
opponent to to play tricks on them but I
like back them into a corner with like
stat debuff something like that like
that works really well
the main conceit though is that your
actions your basic attacks like the gut
punch that will build up what's called
overcharge and overcharge is that red
little bit you see at the bottom next to
that guy's blue mana pool so overcharged
essentially lets you add extra mana to
your pool so you can spend things for
you know cast things for free but it can
also lead to buffs for your attacks so
like this attack cost fifteen
overcharged but it can spend up to forty
and for every additional bit of
overcharge you spend attack on like 0.5
damage or something like that so a lot
of ways it reminds me of like playing
magic in a sense like the way you're
sort of managing these various you know
status conditions and stuff like that
like making sure you have enough to
spend on those different attacks yeah I
mean you can't really get by just by
doing the basic attacks and if you just
do your special abilities well you'll
have no mana left and you're screwed so
you really have to manage like how you
act and what your true what you're
trying to get out of it like you have to
you have to think ahead of time the game
can be really difficult it can be very
punishing but even like standard fights
they still feel very like interesting
and for lack of a better word engaging
and it's just yeah like moments a moment
I'm having a lot of fun with it but the
one thing I would say is if you're gonna
play it right now play it on PC the
PlayStation version on both versions of
the PlayStation 4 I haven't played the
Xbox one so I can't say that but the
PlayStation version has load time issues
that are kind of unfortunate like after
you load a saved game the next fight you
get in there's like a 30 second loading
screen damn well there's a lot of fights
where you'll have like five-second
loading screen beforehand but
doesn't exist on PC and like I said
earlier this is coming to switch but I
don't know the exact release date of
that yet but I'm worried about that
because if it's not optimized properly
for PlayStation 4 which is slightly more
powerful what will we get on switch I
don't know that remains to be seen
unfortunately but I think you should
give this game a shot you should also
read Justin Clarke's review for a second
opinion and battle teasers Network I
love that character design it's it's
like a hunter with a cloak but then
boxing gloves as weapons yeah and so
she's that she's the tank gun
oh really yeah so the big guy is
actually the healer oh my god so they
play with that stuff the big guy with a
Gatling gun for a hand as the healer
yeah that's awesome
that makes me so happy cool this looks
right up my alley
like the overworld itself honestly looks
like Diablo mixed with thermodyne almost
very much cel shading of not cell
shading me too that's not crap but like
the kind of comic book II
color scheme of like Darksiders the
dialog boxes look like comic book yeah
styling yeah I mean this is born from a
comic book artists you know like battle
chasers is a comic book series it exists
nineties and this is just sort of like a
slice of the story yeah Master Quest
gave me on YouTube we just pointed that
out
yo Madera man rera he worked on that but
then after he broke off him and David
Adams I believe they broke off David
Adams worked on Chronos chrono the VR
dr. Chronos he worked on that and then
now they're kind of reforming to do
Darksiders 3 I didn't realize they were
involved with that game Chronos is also
really great yeah just the real quick
sales pitch on that is every time you
die you get older when you come back to
life but as you get older you also get
better at magic and less capable at
physical attacks so it's like death is
an opportunity in and of itself yeah I
think this game is pretty neat it's got
a lot of great voice acting the loot
system kind of sucks I wish that was a
little bit better but are you gonna do
it how so does that suck you don't get
much gold like so this fight well these
are two very strong enemies so I make it
a little more but most fights you get
like one goal
okay and you'll get like some materials
and there is crafting in the game but
it's it's not really easy to tell at
first like okay what do I need for
crafting what don't I need and even then
once you unlock it it's like a very
small amount of things you can make
right away you have to sort of find
different books to teach you how to
craft things which is not a problem but
you sort of get this idea at like I
don't have enough gold to just like
outright buy items so maybe I could sell
my materials but I don't know if that's
actually going to be worth it because
you can you also find loot and dungeons
so am I wasting a crafting opportunity
by spending all this money or do I even
need to craft like the answers aren't
really there all the time it's about a
50 hour game it's how long it took
Justin to finish it there is some
grinding involved like just getting to
the second dungeon right now I'm finding
like yeah I should probably go grind but
for every single level that you hit up
to 23 you get a new ability so you do
kind of feel like your characters are
progressing and more than just stats
like every level is a new chance to do
something new in combat and work
together as a team in different ways and
there are three characters we're seeing
right now but there are I think at least
three more okay yeah I'm just gonna ask
that if it was the same party the whole
game no no so this is as far as I've
gotten them likes five or six hours in
okay yeah I recommend it cool and like
you just said it's probably best to play
on PC right now if possible because of
loading times on Xbox one ps4 you
haven't tried x5 tried Xbox one okay
maybe they'll patch that hopefully I
would hope so cool so yeah again this is
available now if you want to check this
out turn base kind of a loot grind RPGs
or your thing check it out I definitely
want to and the more I see the gameplay
and everything it looks kind of up my
alley
alright I know Joey ye isn't our YouTube
and twitch chats kind of waiting for
this huh yeah we have our PU review
cuphead your review is up on GameSpot as
of what last Thursday I think Friday
Friday something like this so we've
talked about it we've got gameplay
videos we did a bunch of different Joe
we did a really good video on how the
difficulty in this game is I mean you
talk about in your review too but Joey
honed it on how it's fair but difficult
and how it adds to the game but this
game is super tough for those who don't
know obviously like it's kind of it's
been in development for how many years
now before and we've known about it for
three known about it for a while and
course it's its hand-drawn 2d animation
all
1930s Mickey Mouse Oswald cartoons but
it's very difficult to which kind of
platformer and sort of like cinema but
more of a platformer outside
mm-hmm well yeah there are platforming
levels the boss fights themselves are
much more like something like like
contra okay Mega Man may be a tough Mega
Man mm contra is better yeah country
yeah baby after watching this obvious
very gorgeous game very very novel
looking and for a video game I mean hand
drawing all these different animations
just seems obviously it's no surprise it
took as long to make as it did but it's
out on Xbox one finally didn't the devs
like refinance their houses and stuff to
get it done - I probably went into this
it's really gory yeah it's I've never
seen a video game that's that is so
unique looking yeah that's not a word
that I like to throw around yeah there's
not many things are unique but this is
unique yeah you talk talk about the
difficulty that's the everybody is
wondering like is it is it punishingly
part or is it is it fair or is it like
kind of I mean look it's fair because it
doesn't really pull any cheap moves I
mean that's pretty much it like there's
no like crazy surprises we're like what
the hell I got caught from something off
screen or you know there's none of that
but it likes to throw a lot of things at
you
and as you can see it's also very busy
on screen so it can be a little bit
difficult to keep track of everything
but you know a fight when you win it is
like two and a half minutes tops
and often fights can be around a minute
if you're really good so if you suck
you're gonna die and you're gonna get to
start real quickly because there's like
one set it's not I don't even think
there's more there's no load yeah it's
just like start the fight over again
here you go and it's that sort of
mentality where you know you know you're
gonna die because you need to sort of
study the various patterns that the
bosses will will show you an attack with
my one criticism for the difficulty is
not necessarily that it's specifically
too hard but that it's inconsistent and
sometimes you'll find a boss fight where
the boss will you know in a certain
there's like three or four phases to a
lot of fights and like a boss can throw
out many different attacks within a
particular phase but they won't always
throw out the same attacks
so you may find yourself like stuck in
an unfortunate dice roll of okay well
this round I have to deal with these
attacks which I've never dealt with
before or these this combination is just
more difficult than the other
alternatives and so it can be like
frustrating in a way like if you beat
your head against the wall and then you
get a really easy run and you win that
way and it's like I didn't want to win
like that like I wanted to win against
the thing that I couldn't beat but but
more often than not it's it's really
hard to beat these levels and you will
find yourself not so concerned about the
randomness your trying to just survive
as much as possible
maybe they're in the reasoning for that
would be maybe somewhat justified for
like hey I'm I'm not necessarily playing
the exact same thing over and over again
yeah that's got to be the argument there
it's just it can prove frustrating well
totally I definitely had that like
there's I I've played I played a lot
over the weekend and there's those Frog
brothers sure the earlier ones they had
that one platform note was it platform
one there's that one of their final
phases that like I hate it yeah got it
it was like oh I'm totally done but you
you're you're kind of on point where I
beat them when I didn't get that one
phase I think was a couple at forming
like drums or something like that I just
couldn't nail but yeah I mean it's there
is something to be said about like even
if it like the the phases were like
structured and repetitive it's just just
there's something about knowing that
like this is a really hard game and it's
fine that you're dying like I'm
surprised how often I'm like replaying
the same thing and it's like Jesus like
20 minutes went by like yeah and I'm not
upset
mm-hmm right it's just the music and in
the art the art style it's so refreshing
that you just just you never get bored
right and yeah like you don't get upset
because you know it's not the game's
fault you know it's like something that
you need to improve right like you'll
walk away from it like it's thinking
like I need to reset myself right I need
to fix this from my time watching it and
I haven't touched the game since like an
xbox showcase two years ago but because
it's kind of flat and also the fact that
there's so many moving parts the
animations I sometimes like watching
people have trouble seeing what's going
to hurt me and
what is actually just part of the
animations in the background this is a
good example but I mean but that's maybe
that's part of learning like like I
watching this roller coaster section you
can jump on the front of the roller
coaster the face but you obviously the
spikes are gonna hurt you that makes
sense but there are other times when I
see when I'm watching like Joey play in
the auto oh I didn't that little thing
it's the parrying if that's why your no
no I'm not I'm not Hank knows that's why
he was able to like right no I'm saying
but I if I were to be playing for the
first time and I'm trying to learn
what's going to hurt there's a bunch of
things on screen that like don't
actually hurt you like I watched earlier
when you're fighting that like ice-cream
castle boss there was a bunch of things
that they were it wasn't even like her
projectiles necessarily but it just it's
kind of tough to see in all this
animation it's gorgeous but maybe I'm
sure once I start playing and I kind of
get in that you get in that mode yeah
where you're not actually used to that
point where your focus so much on one
thing that you're not even looking
around the screen yeah sort of you learn
the space and you learn how you move
within it that you it's a second thought
maybe just yeah like maybe it's cuz as a
bystander I'm just focusing on how good
it looks yeah yeah that's that's the
problem with watching is like if you
haven't played it can be hard to tell
but I think it's I mean from from what I
read in your review Peter and like what
I've seen it's it seems like you learned
the language of the very much just you
know what's going on screen yeah yeah
and you learn the boss as various tells
that like you know indicate okay what
they're gonna do next and I had it's a
very very tough game and there's a high
ceiling for scale as well like even if
you can't beat all the bosses there's
still things you can do to obviously run
through faster now there's things on the
map that'll sort of like hint it like
maybe if you do this a certain way you
will unlock a thing
this is Joey playing by the way Joey
it's really good he put up he put up
like a boss run video with no damage on
YouTube in our GameSpot site if you want
to check that out because it is
entrancing to watch when someone's
really good at it
I want to try it out so badly he's like
clearly not human it's amazing yeah yeah
I had to like pour fuel down his spine
to the other day he fell asleep I find -
yeah he's a robot
we were we were talking with the end of
the day yesterday and he came over and
he was he had been playing cup head all
day and he like wasn't making sense no
it was bleeding yeah hey Joey and he was
like hon just need a break and we were
like oh my god are you alright he's like
why it's like he's not there you told me
is that a cup handles like growing up
runs headlong into a car
people are saying the the casino boss
has RNG aspects and then Joey was like
well yeah it's a casino there's gambling
involved there's like randomness it's
basically like you just have to fight a
series of bosses and the ones you fight
are determined by chance but that's the
same as any oh it's night that the
casino thing is the boss run yeah okay
gotcha that makes sense but every every
boss fight has like I like that they're
like kind of like I mean it's it's
almost a narrative but like oh yeah oh
those were like the phases of each box
yeah like the cat and like the rack the
rack so there's like one were you like
you're fighting this rat and then he
goes away because the cat comes out of
the house and you're like fighting the
cat and you got through a few phases
with the cat when you finally kill a cat
and like lunch is over and its face it
turns out it's a robot its face opens up
and the rats inside of it like oh [ __ ]
the ultimate in the the story in the
beginning or the set up - like why
cuphead and his bro bug man or stuff
yeah McMahon is like they they were they
were going crazy in a The Devil's casino
and gambled but it doubles like now you
gotta go like collect my debt so you're
kind of killing maybe potentially
innocent like creatures you're
collecting their souls and handing them
over to the devil all because you owe me
a little
cashola hey Lawson our twitch chat is
saying is there a debate about skipping
difficult sections and games going
around right now cuz he said like this
he saw like arguments about like if
people who aren't necessarily like good
at twitch games but still want to play
this I heard there be like a way to
yep stuff I have seen people talking
about like you know maybe
differently-abled players like having
trouble like if you have like I actually
have a friend who was like one hand that
like her hands fine but it's just not as
dexterous that's her that's her other
hand and it can be harder to play like
twitchy games so I have seen people
talking about that I haven't really seen
like anything conclusive I also saw
somebody saying like if you have the
option to skip a boss then maybe that
boss wasn't necessary in the first place
like people are talking about that right
now I guess right I mean yeah I mean a
broader discussion there is like if a
game has a really heavy story and has a
lot of combat and you don't actually
care about the combat should you be
allowed to skip it and I mean we all I
don't know if were gonna share our
opinions on that but I mean it's it's
yeah why not yeah it's like why not have
skippable yeah yes I saw Guba friend of
the podcast was saying maybe it's just
like not every game needs to be for
everyone but like cuphead kind of maybe
reignites that argument or that question
because it's so gorgeous it's kind of so
charming like it has a simple mode like
and fight bosses on easy mode yes can't
get to the end right just looking at it
I'm like even if this wasn't a difficult
game I would super want to play it no
matter what just to see that play out
because it's gorgeous and it seems so
novel but great but then the
counter-argument to play devil's
advocate is maybe you just need to play
a different game and this game's not for
you or maybe people shouldn't get each
other share things because they want to
feel yeah but I hate all those arguments
yeah every one of those arguments but
does but this this actually came up I
think it was this is a weird comparison
but Legend Zelda Triforce heroes and you
can just like essentially skip whole
parts of dungeons in that and I felt in
that game because it wasn't overly
difficult I was like why can you even
skip these doesn't that just devalue
these sections the why but like why I
include them if you can skip these
cuphead it makes a little more sense
because just so difficult well is the
thing also thing called self-control I
mean if a thing is skippable and you
don't want to skip it just don't do it
don't it's not a problem for you and can
get over your yeah that's the thing is
late like this same friend with the the
one hand it's a little like like I don't
know how to put it less effective less
effective yeah
like instead of playing through all the
metal games just watched like a supercut
of it as if it were a movie and wooden
house
yeah and that was like really in the
middle you earn those cutscenes calories
she didn't beat that boss like people
people got really like I shared this
with like some like gamer friends and
they were kind of like well you know
like doesn't that defeat the purpose of
like playing a game then and there's
some games like for example like I
talked about
undertale before but i think like
undertale blends combat with like
character development really well and
that's something that like i would
encourage you to play and that's another
game that if you watched on youtube
there's a little call-outs in these
difficult boss battles like being like
oh you're just watching this right now
or for the people watching at home or
whatever yeah but it's like telling
people that like they have to hold their
fork in their left hand yeah I mean you
just wanna watch it like just do it it
doesn't I don't want a police have
somebody consumes like a work of art or
fiction or media or whatever you call it
or anything are you - I was saying what
if they consigned like certain attacks
to one button so it like you should
still experience the boss there's game
Capcom vs. SNK 2 that was on GameCube of
complex fighting game that on any other
platform can be complex and I gave you
controls you actually had just like one
button super moves so you could still
participate in conversations about
certain boss fights without like
suffering through it if you're not yeah
whatever reason not able to play at
someone else's level even just the fact
that like match-three puzzle games that
are color based have colorblind modes
right it's like I mean it's the same
concept of just making this more
accessible to a wider group of people
and let's see what's wrong with that
and again like playing devil's advocate
thinking from the developers side do you
think in some cases that could
compromise their vision for what the
game is or how they want people to
experience it does that matter to me as
a player like maybe like thanking you
from the Creator side of the game saying
we the difficulty is inherent to this
game Rahmi user made a very good post
this morning that a lot of this argument
assumes that developers understand
difficulty and balance yeah when they're
they're trying to figure it out
there's no formula for what should be
difficult how it should be difficult how
that makes the game rewarding or how
that even defines the substance of a
game mm-hmm they are you know these
people work in a closed environment
sometimes they can focus test it's not
until it's put out in the wild that
people really understand what they're
working with
so to assume that developers know
everything is just the false yeah Keith
Richards liver for 20 I mean uh I'm
disabled and beat Dark Souls and
blood-borne it wouldn't have meant as
much if there were skippable bosses
maybe that's more of a long lines what I
was thinking of like is that difficulty
inherent to the game and if you can't
skip it does that actually make it not
blood-borne not dark souls not cuphead
anymore no okay not in my opinion okay
something you're on the same page Kelly
I mean yeah I just really think that
like honestly with any piece of media or
art whatever you want to call any game
in particular it's it's more important
how you interpret it than how it was
intended yeah and most in most
situations I don't think that way when
it's like racist yeah but like you know
like for example Pokemon originally was
just like collect all the Pokemon then
people were like nah we're gonna make
them fight at the highest level right
and then they started putting that in
the games like it's just like and
speaking tend to look at what they do
with their games now like if you die a
bunch of times like in a new Mario
platformer like 5 times it's like do you
what do you want us to like give you a
little bit of an assist
Mario Plus rabbits before each fight
says easy mode button press Y for easy
mode sure I mean I don't think there's
any shame in wanting to play something
easy especially because like you
ultimately decide how you want to spend
your time and you only have so much time
to spend and if I want to experience
Mario Plus Rabbids without like wanting
to pull my hair out and that's my choice
yeah I mean I will say to your point
somewhat is that if it presents it
before every fight as just this overt
thing I could see that being an
impediment to your you know
understanding of what this is if you're
trying to make it difficult but I think
there is a way to put those options in a
game that you know with finesse mm-hmm
and if it's done in a way that that
isn't so overt that
you feel like why am I doing this yeah
then that's cool right
mentioning Dark Souls and blood-borne
you can do it deprived run and that's
super hard because you chose to do that
but you don't have to do well super hard
for the first few hours of the game
until you can build your character out
but that's a choice to make it harder if
you have that dexterity and want to
improve it and that's the opposite side
like that's not a problem
right that's sure making a game more
difficult my choice is not the problem
right it's yeah the bait arises over
this is it should is cuphead still
cuphead if it's not difficult it's the
difference it's a it's modern art it's
the modern art to be yeah like do you
interpret the art as the viewer or does
the Cordish convey it right like that is
the separation between fine art fine
traditional art and modern art and it's
either you know one is for you or it
isn't that doesn't make either one
invalid yeah and it makes I guess it
makes sense that cuphead might have like
Errol Moss twitch it's always on our in
our twitch chat was saying that to bake
up maybe it was on some sort of forum
there's something that got reignited
cuphead makes sense because it's super
difficult and so like Joey loves the
difficulty he put up that video about
why the difficulty made him like it more
but as you're saying someone else could
like it for totally different reasons
like if you just want to be a part of
that charming gorgeous world and that's
if you maybe you don't need the
difficulty so that and that is like I I
totally respect and understand
everyone's point Billy perk up kit
cuphead when I'm hearing like we're talk
about the rat level with a boss and
you're like did you see the ending I was
like yeah I actually didn't see the
ending because when I play with my buddy
on simple because we both sucked he got
the true ending of that whole thing and
I missed it so then it is the attitude
of like well now I am the whole cup a
decision unique case where it's just a
gorgeous game that you want to get every
ounce of that visual so now it's like
okay cool well I guess I have to play on
regular or else I'm not gonna see the
final stage and that's like the case for
like almost every boss right absolutely
every boss there in the third if you
play on simple the third phase whatever
the last phase is and you also can't get
to the final world if you only beat
bosses on simple you have to know that
every boss on regular then to Mike's
question-is cup head still cup head
without difficulty that's just like
simplified cup head but isn't it like
it's the same thing but that's assuming
that like they're different said
everybody who plays cup head is the
difficulty means the same thing to them
right right yeah there are ways of doing
that that that can work right like cuz
even along with the third phase being
stripped the amount of enemies is
removed for simple so why not just do
that you know balance it to the degree
where I'm getting the length and the
breadth of like each level but every
time like that's that's that should be
the case like because why not right I've
not heard a really solid argument for
why that shouldn't be a thing yeah oh
well um one last side note 1337 studio
and the YouTube chat said the music
soundtrack for Cup head was recorded
with a live band yeah that doesn't
surprise me at this point with this game
like it makes sense that's awesome I
mean even like the announcer which I
frickin adore everytime you start up a
new run let's go she's about to begin
what I'm getting is like the announcer
like you the the muddiness and like the
muffled and like that mic you know it
was like an old-ass condenser where the
hell they had right yeah back in the
1930s like it just sounds so authentic
yeah that yeah Ryan Schubert worked here
at GameSpot he's in the YouTube chat
said imagine if you couldn't watch the
end of a movie because you were in a big
enough fan of the rest of it seriously
yeah yeah you want dessert but you
didn't appreciate that that dinner I
made you didn't appreciate that meatloaf
you don't deserve dessert oh yeah when
you wear a band t-shirt it gives cuphead
by the way because every time I see
someone in the office in headphones on
night sobriety things I think there's
like assignment this there's jazz
pertaining to like the boss type like
there's like that one plant guy who I
swear he's like I'm more like a salsa
maybe like Mamba yeah like he's like
dancing
killer or it's like the the rat I feel
like I is like more like ragtime yeah
there's a lot of different different
influences but definitely from that same
era for sure
cool awesome so yeah go play cop heads
on Xbox one it's gorgeous it's and sorry
PC windows correct yeah cross by cross
five hundos ten name anyone box one yeah
play play anywhere yes play anywhere
what were you saying
it looks like you had a some gonna say
two-player mode is kind of hectic oh
yeah yeah we should talk about that
cuphead and mug bro is his name ugh bros
better all right cuphead and mug bro you
can pee in a co-op mode but you that was
a big draw of the game from you every
time I play demos it was co-op with
someone else like boss run kind of
things but you said that's a little too
much in terms on screen it's a lot to
deal with especially well I mean I was
in the zone playing single-player and
people came up like hey let's play co-op
and I was like all right yes I threw off
my entire game I started throwing up at
the station every five minutes but shake
and he review again it's not even like
Eric tastes its next time it's not even
faze them anymore he slides over an
extra buck co-op and cup head yeah it
gets too much well that goes back to my
question like it seems like there's a
lot of stimuli on the screen but when
it's co-op it seems like it just is it
and I think that they they ramped up the
there as well okay there as I was
getting further later yeah I was getting
farther by myself than with the second
player doing the same things so that to
me says yeah it wants twice the damage
okay however much more okay I think I
don't know if that's been confirmed one
way or another but that's the way it
felt
it's the PSA sorry from Joey again in
the YouTube chat he says the from his
experience the Windows Store version has
some
issues oh I saw that that save glitch
did you see yes I did early on it was
just deleting people saves if you did
was it just a glitch it was a big thing
you could I don't remember the details
or DC used to be refused that polygon
was saying he got it and it was just
like the worst feeling ever
I mean it's obviously worse in a
difficult game oh my god and apparently
they just went in I think it was like
trying to reload it wasn't even like
booting up the Xbox and continuing it
was he died and it couldn't reload that
save so like he just lost and went back
like a stage three hours ago or
something no yeah and that sounds awful
I don't know you would walk away they
exist maybe they fixed them since I read
that two days ago but Joey said there
are some save issues on Windows so be
cognizant of that I guess were you gonna
say something else about cuphead we were
talking about co-op I don't know where
we left off but yeah I played a lot with
my buddy over the weekend and like we
were doing the simple modes for which
are only for the boss is right the
running guns are all are going to be the
same difficulty I think so running guns
were that hard were easier yeah I fell
yeah they really are they're an
opportunity to earn coins and coins you
spend on new weapons and passive bus an
easier in the sense of like you know
that's what we're like the rollercoaster
boss the the theme park that is hectic
right there's so much going on that's
where you lose track of your character
like when they're tossing like the
platforming in there god that has got to
be so difficult we didn't play it but
like again the running guns which is a
side-scrolling but certain levels were
bearable but I will also say that like
the more we played the more I could feel
like you were learning and getting
better I mean that goes with obviously
the game in general but but then the
other thing too was like whenever
someone one of us died hands down that
pertaineth at the person still left
playing got farther than the two people
going like every time it was like hey
this is easy now worried about another
person like yeah the one thing is that
you can revive someone when they die
right you have a very small window of
time to make that happen and you can
also just screw yourself up right trying
to save someone yeah you have to
basically Perry their ghost as it floats
off the screen but parrying is tricky in
itself anyway I was yeah we would keep
we kept getting to the final boss he
kept trying to revive me I was like
don't like don't
the movies when someone gets like during
a battle they get or a fight they get
the [ __ ] kicked out of them and then
like something their friend go that the
hell they were like no no I need to get
up themselves and like prove it to
everybody
no look like Apollo Creed don't you
throw that towel rocky I had one who was
like you both kept like revive each
other
all right cup had Xbox one she is out
now and II thought we've got a bunch of
videos Joey did a he talked more in
depth about the difficulty in a video
essay he made it's very good you should
go check that out it's pretty short -
it's like Forrest minutes maybe less so
it's you can watch it right after the
lobby one more thing I want to talk
about before we call it quits
battlefront 2 beta again Rob you got up
at like 6:30 to play today so from my
understanding it's Naboo from what we
saw at e3 and then what was the other
one is it the space battle that's right
owed over over like that fond or what
the what is fond or did you make that
out like you don't know what fat dory oh
no hit me with your I don't know your
intelligence I think it's the planet
that iodine is from no she's from artist
but she's from danwon don't we - where's
var dos Sonora and outer rim colony no
sorry oh god sorry could be Mike
[Music]
yes Starfighter mode this Tatooine right
here this is no this is the other one
they showed off this is uh taka Dona
Jaco Don I don't do this anymore
Star Wars Tatiana Maz is castle mines
castle from was awakened
Jesus Christ yeah with let's get through
this this is the palace from force
awakens okay gotcha it looks gorgeous
I would only played a few hours this
morning but I was walking around as a
first-order trooper and I think this was
a little bit in the last game the
Battlefront 2015 but like there's what
you saw it off all fresh in this
pristine white suit and there was like
so much mud I swear it was like so cool
to see like in third-person like just my
whole outfit just like covered in mud
dude this this game looks better than
ever
sounds
the aesthetic is so spot-on just like
the last game it is so cool to just soak
in I'm playing on PC like maxed out it's
running pretty damn well yeah that being
said this is like a strike mode it's
like a tone down like 8v8 more objective
bass you know you're like doing like an
arm disarm I think we're you know
defending your your mate from your
you're just you're running like a bomb
and you're defending your teammates from
the rebels we're trying to yes maz
kanata's cantina paso its objective base
there's I'm sure there are other types
of strikes and I like this a lot because
there's like tone down I was dying
less than the previous Naboo mode just
like that was stupid that was the look
technically cool yeah right a problem I
had with the first one was so many of
the different weapons weren't actually
all that different so you get into these
one-on-one fights with another guy and
be like who started shooting first
that's the person who's gonna win you
shoppers yeah who shot home yeah and so
Mike you've played a little bit so we
know no you haven't
Oh III III yeah so it's the same case
where they definitely spend more time
with these weapons and diversify them
because that was one of the issues of
many with the last game with it was was
that all the weapons kind of just fell
samey
yeah what is the distinction dispenser
shot no recoil
right so you have like the weapons feel
different like I would say like more we
could foil but also like they're unique
to like they're they have like the
active reload so each one has that like
you know that little scale and they're
different so like that's another way of
mastering that gun because they overheat
pretty often so if you get if you nail
that like you know like there's like you
could reload quicker or you can get a
bit of a damage boost in the yellow like
that smaller area to hit so that's neat
I think that's pretty cool and the
looked like there were other weapons
that were moddable
you could add like a scope or other
things to yeah so I progressed
system so they're worried I have that
the beta does well the progressions the
progression system the beta I'm sorry in
the last game was just getting new stuff
right
it was just like getting weapons and
that was about it
setec a new character mami and abilities
here and there like struck those were
the star cards and that's the same for
here but there's but their class
specific and they do a lot more far as
the star cards now yeah so as far as the
beta how it works what do I begin you
you get luke rates now that's how you
get these for the most part so it's
another game with loot crate system and
I'm undecided because I so I started
playing this morning and you start off
with no star cards in this beta as you
play you you you know you unlock star
cards and you start throwing them on and
you know they're doing things like each
class and their clasps is specific so I
would get like a heavy class health
regen that's like 5% quicker because
it's an uncommon star card the
legendaries are like I don't know 20%
like it ranges but there's something to
be said about like when I was playing
this morning it was like this feeling of
like I'm weak as [ __ ] and there are
other people who have these these boosts
we talked about this a few months ago
whether this game was pay to win based
on that video they released on the loot
crate's and everything right it's like
from this morning and like for the few
hours of playing it's not that great of
a feeling right yeah just to start this
game and this is beta granted but
imagine like what if I pick this game up
like two months later mm-hm and all
these people have legendaries Ledger's
by the way you can't so wouldn't it one
of the other systems is that you get
credits as well credits you can oh no
I'm sorry
you you just mental like duplicate cards
which then turn into like crafting like
points whatever and then I can take said
card and turn it from an uncommon to
like an epic okay it stops at legendary
legendary czar all chance by Lutz for
loot crate's so that's that's the
upsetting part so I can't necessarily
max out
you know a specific class again like our
specific to the fighter like starship
that's a frustrating frustrating aspect
of it um games like destiny get around
that because their loot base by having
you know like the weapon stats get
erased in like a regular 4v4 deathmatch
kind of but when you're Brian banner
then we're coming to play yeah so it
would make sense if battlefront you had
a version where the loot actually had
its effects and then there are other
ways you could play where it's just a
level playing field but based on the
beta again this comes on November 17th
we haven't played the full game yet are
they doing anything like that or this is
like pervasive across all modes that
your stats are going to be in effect
it's it's all notes to my understanding
and granted like the you know what is
being changed they are it is minor right
like it's not like substantial or to my
understanding you know like what's the
difference between really like 5% or 10%
well I mean that's not that soon yeah
well I know the head but for like sorry
but oh wow what that actually means like
cuz that 5% that translates to seconds I
guess I mean it's it's a weird numbers
game but like how does it actually like
effect but it but again it's still the
knowledge of this is happening you know
II mean like I don't know other people
are begging for more money is gonna be
better than someone who practice a lot
right on all cases but I wasn't
complaining with a stacked deck yeah but
that being said like I don't know like I
you just just want to keep playing it
because I don't but I got cuz I don't
really have an answer right this is just
how I'm feeling of the like 2-3 hours of
this morning and this is weird thing
like this is beta like oh man I don't I
wonder what else to do it comes out soon
but I wonder if this is gonna be the
case when I start the game yeah and I
have no cards I hope not I hope that's
not the case I hope like everyone is on
a pretty solid playing field this is
we're watching the actual like space
battle right now how does this feel cuz
these there were space battles in the
first game but there were specific modes
and they were just boring dogfights as
opposed to so good the original
battlefront - which had awesome you know
you can board the ships as the marine
classes yeah and then you can actually
specific things on the ship strictly
combat aerial combat but it's better
this time around
there are like more obstacles and you
know you get to fly into this Space
Station and like as like an objective
you know you don't disable the generator
and then fly inside and disable the core
so there's a lot going on with
dogfighting and stuff and my favorite
part is that there's actually like one
to one role so I can actually manual
role opposed to auto role from the last
game where you do a flip and you're
upside down and there's it's like auto
correcting and then that's when you
crash on the ground it's not necessarily
that anymore I had I was part with
controller because it's a mouse and
keyboard flying is just bonkers but
sensitivity was really high I was I'm
still like trying to get a hang of it
again looks like all the audio is so
freakin cool like they co ham with the
aesthetics tie interceptors by the way
are the coolest they're so dark starship
oh man like space craft in Star Wars
yeah stupid
I can't wait to blow up B wings left and
right will there be wings in this game
no they're not good do you want to
destroy them or would you rather they
not really I would rather they be in the
game like giving he gives me [ __ ]
because I like the B wing there so are
you talking about Darkseid what else was
there to talk about
don't you like B mix no I'm just saying
the hate is flowing through oh cool no
I'm cool but I want to play more of this
game and another thing to say is that
the loot crate's
how you are getting them because you do
you get you can get them automatically
based on like just experience so like I
was flying a good now this morning I got
a Starfighter specific loot crate that
what gave me were like three items that
were pertaining to like starships so to
classify these so if I played a bunch of
like the assault class I'm gonna get
inevitably a assault class loot crate
which so it is specific like you can
kind of hone your progression opposed to
what and to my initial understanding was
like you're just gonna get a loot crate
it's gonna be random as [ __ ] yeah
you just it's just gonna spread out all
over the place and you can't like hone
any like oh I like this gun I want to
get like a scope on it or something like
that I think I think it can be specific
a nice flying this stuff yeah anyways
I'm I'm rambling one morning yeah so
this is the if you pre-ordered the game
you could play this right now on ps4
Xbox one PC the open beta for everyone
starts Friday a game releases in
November 17th Rob based on the beta any
last thoughts before we inevitably talk
about it again in November I am excited
to play more of this more so than the
first game you're enjoying hell yeah
hell yeah and that's mainly because it
just it's it's the first thing better
than the last game I really do think
that is the first case was great at just
being of like a good looking kind of fun
to jump into Star Wars game but it wore
thin after a while when I realized there
wasn't much below the surface because
yeah you could you know you weren't
necessarily like it was just like all
jumbled jumbled in random it was like
hopefully you got in the next way if you
find the icon on the map yeah like I for
one love like the dogfighting and like
that's mmm so much more refined and I
can like stick to these modes but also
in the then the other modes you know the
class or sorry these star fighter mode I
can play but there's no galactic
conquest were like you can get into a
Starfighter way easier with battle
points get a couple kills you're in one
guaranteed that's great and there's a
lot more teamwork with like you know
your points raised if you were like are
huddled in a team so that's that's
helping oppose like Alaska where you
totally like just lone wolf in it so
that's neat I'll stop talking a little
bit today like I said in a couple days
everybody can play it but if you
preorder this game there's no like EA
access right now it's just pretty much
simply open beta Friday you can just go
get into that and try it out before
release is November 17th for ps4 Xbox
one and PC from EA motive also this
lines up pretty nicely for the
supposedly ed i trailer which straps
monday so after you get your Star Wars
go with the beta you get a nice hot
trailer didn't you and that brought
didn't you tell us that there was gonna
be a trailer like a couple weeks ago and
it turned out to be a lie no but I
preface that as saying it's a rumor
happen oh I see avoiding responsibility
when you're inevitably wrong what's
wrong to you why do you I'm just kidding
I saw Josh on the twitch chat earlier
and he was the one talking about it last
time it happened dude all right cool so
that's our show as always we have a
giveaway
speaking of axiom verge on switch we
have 25 North America codes and 25
European codes so if you don't follow a
GameSpot go do so on Twitter retweet the
tweet about the giveaway she will be
putting that up momentarily if you're in
the twitch chat she'll also be putting
the link in there and then Friday will
pick winners and 25 random people in
North America 25 random switch owners
and Europe will get axiom verge on
Nintendo switch I highly recommend
playing that it's the multiverse Edition
I don't I am assuming there's added
stuff that I never played on the
original one but um yes so you'll get
the whole package for free if you
retweet us that's our show I totally
forgot about something we're streaming
to Erte an hour today at 2 p.m. Pacific
join us and save the universe or just
the galaxy no the universe is a pretty
bold task that's it cool awesome
we have streams every day at 11 a.m. but
later today we're gonna be doing 2 p.m.
Pacific playing battlefront 2 as Rob
just said thank you to Eric ty Richard
levy on the site key in the back we have
there's a couple reviews I can't even
talk about that are going up soon I got
in trouble the other day for talking
about a game that we have ok hatton time
hopefully tomorrow you're aiming for
tomorrow 3d platformer are you working
on anything Pete review wise or you kind
of have a little well oh well I've got
some versus reviews probably going up
today okay I feel like gun Dan's you can
get your gun damn on next week shadow 4
releases on Tuesday evil within 2 on
Friday
being a bethesda game we might not have
the review up on release day who knows
what we're gonna happen with that but as
always thank you everybody joining the
YouTube chat twitch chat on GameSpot we
will be back next week same time
Wednesday 11:00 a.m. Pacific in San
Francisco thank you for joining and
don't forget to retweet that giveaway
tweet and we'll see you next week
[Music]